[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about how
to use the fast Fourier transform to
compress images and we walk through the
basic idea that when you Fourier
transform an image most of the Fourier
coefficients are quite small and can be
truncated or thresholded away so you can
zero out all of the small Fourier
coefficients retaining only the largest
1% or 2% of those FFT values and then
when you inverse Fourier transform that
thresholded FFT signal you recover the
original image with relatively low
degradation okay
and so the compression comes about by
only saving these largest one percent or
two percent fourier coefficients okay so
now we're going to code this up in
Python and here is the jupiter notebook
so okay we're going to use matplotlib x'
image package and we're going to import
image read so that we can load our image
and I'm going to load this image of the
Afghan girl from National Geographic so
let me run this it's going to take a
moment to plot okay good
so this is the image that we're going to
be working with this is actually a
relatively high resolution image it
looks kind of small here but this is I
think about 1400 by 1400 pixels okay so
this is what we're gonna compress and
notice here I have my 256 minus a where
a was the image that I read in I'm only
doing this 256 - because I've inverted
my color scheme for this black
background and these color ranges go
from 0 to 256 so if I take 256 minus a
that flips the image color so it looks
okay on this inverted scheme okay so
next what we're going to do is we're
going to Fourier transform this image so
FFT 2 is built into numpy so we're going
to FFT to our image and be
is essentially be is what happens when
you take this a which has three colour
channels RGB red green blue and you
basically average over all of those
color channels you obtain a grayscale
image B okay so I'm going to convert
this color image to a grayscale image
because I just want to work on an array
for simplicity I don't want to work on
three colour channels so I'm only going
to work on gray so B is the grayscale
image so we're going to FFT to this
image that's you FFT all the rows than
all the columns then what I'm going to
do we're going to this remember this is
an image compression example so we're
gonna Fourier transform then what we're
going to do is we're going to try to
keep only the largest 10% so point 1.0
5.0 1.00 to we're going to keep the
largest 10% of the Fourier coefficients
the largest 5% of the Fourier
coefficients and the largest 1% of the
Fourier coefficients and finally the
largest point two percent of the Fourier
coefficients and the way we're gonna do
this is we're going to take our Fourier
transform and we're literally going to
turn this into a really really big
vector and sort all of the values from
largest to smallest and if we want to
keep the top 10% largest values we just
pick the first 10% of that sorted
reshaped FFT and that will determine
what the threshold value is okay so
that's how we obtain this threshold
value here is we basically turn this
into a vector we sort it and then we
pick the first 10% or the first 1% 5%
0.2% we obtain that value that's the
threshold above which we keep the
Fourier coefficients below which we
truncate and we create this big index
matrix here which basically takes the it
finds all Fourier coefficients that have
a magnitude larger than threshold and it
sets those values equal to one this in
this index matrix this index matrix has
zeros and ones ones where the Fourier
coefficient is larger than threshold
zeroes where it's smaller than codes and
threshold okay and so that index array
is basically going to be a mask right
it's all zeros and ones zeros for the
Fourier coefficients we want to truncate
ones for the ones we want to keep and so
we dot times we just multiply this
element wise by our Fourier transform B
and what that does is that hard
thresholds everything that is smaller
than our threshold so it manually zeros
out everything that's below threshold
and only keeps the largest values here
and then finally we're going to inverse
Fourier transform IFFT to to get back to
our original signal here and then I'm
gonna plot that for you okay and there's
kind of a typo here this shouldn't be a
low this should be be low here but it
doesn't really really matter okay good
so I'm gonna run this code and we're
gonna see what happens okay so it's
running now it's thinking and we're
going to see what the image quality is
when I only keep the first 10% the first
5% the first one percent and the first
point two percent of the largest Fourier
coefficients okay so when I keep the
first ten percent of the Fourier
coefficients you can see that you get
almost perfect image reconstruction so
this looks very very much like the
original high resolution grayscale image
you can see like a strand of hair
details in the iris and cornea very high
fidelity reproduction of this image and
a compression ratio of ten so we've
thrown away 90% of the information and
only with the largest 10% inverse
Fourier transforming we're able to
almost perfectly reconstruct similarly
5% is quite good it's you have to zoom
in actually to see any imperfections in
this pretty much all of the features are
also being preserved here even at 1%
yeah it's really quite good this is a
hundred times compression ratio so we're
throwing out 99% of the image
information in this image and again if
you zoomed in you'd probably have some
loss of detail in the iris and in the
cornea but really like for the
purpose of an image at this size on this
screen you really can't tell the
difference so you can get away with a
hundred times compression ratio and then
finally just to make kind of an absurd
point this is 500 times compression so
we're throwing away 99.8% finally you
can start to visibly see degradation in
the image quality here right so this
looks like a grainy image now we've lost
a lot of the kind of defined details of
this image but but even up to the
compression ratio of 100 you get a
pretty good compression so that's quite
impressive okay okay so what are some
other points I want to make out here
some other points I think are
interesting sometimes I show pictures of
like fluffy dog and those you know a
fluffy dog in a grass field and that's
actually harder to compress so at the
same compression ratios you actually get
worse performance and the reason is is
because hair and fur and grass have a
lot of texture and these are really
there's a lot of high-frequency content
in hair and fur and grass they actually
you need to keep to reconstruct that
image and so high-frequency stuff is
harder to represent and in fact this is
actually this was a big deal in Pixar
when they started making these movies so
Toy Story was their first one and if you
remember all of the characters in Toy
Story had plastic skin okay so every no
hair no fur no grass it was all you know
smooth plastic skin because it's much
much easier to work in a compressed
representation and to render those types
of objects than it is to render hair and
fur and grass and so it was a big leap
from from Toy Story 2 something like
Monsters Inc where they finally figured
out how to render you know a big hairy
monster because that's that's a lot
harder a lot higher frequency content a
lot more detail that you have to you
have to render that you can't kind of
just compress out okay so that's kind of
interesting too also the larger the
image the more compressible it is so if
I have an ultra ultra high-res
image there's more information that's
redundant that I can compress out so
I'll get a higher compression ratio the
bigger the image is and if I have a
smaller image lower res you need more of
those Fourier coefficients to to
reconstruct the image okay so those are
all kind of pro tips that you need to
keep in mind and the last thing I want
to show you this is kind of a fun
example I was actually explaining this
to my mom kind of how this image
compression works and what the Fourier
transform means intuitively and so I
decided to cook up this example where I
take this image and I basically plot the
pixel intensity as a surface okay so
you're gonna need a couple of a couple
of Python libraries to make this
something that can be rotated so this is
this is my code here it's cut off a
little bit but you can see nothing fancy
I'm just picking a color map and no edge
color okay and this might take a little
while to run yeah it's pretty fast okay
so this is that exact same picture of
the Afghan girl but rendered as a
surface plot so the brighter pixels in
in her face are both brighter and taller
in this kind of elevation map okay and
this is super cool if we start to rotate
this image down you're gonna see
something amazing happen okay so we're
rotating this down and this is I'm
claiming her face plotted as a surface
and what you can see if I get this just
right it's a little bit hard to do okay
my Python is barely cooperating yes I
get it just right you can see that this
is actually her face kind of as a
mountain landscape of pixel intensity so
the the whites of her eyes are the
brightest pixels those are the tallest
peaks in this kind of mountainous
landscape pixel intensity okay and then
you know her nose is also kind of a
mountain structure and all of the the
intensity can be thought of as this
topography in this landscape and so what
we're trying to do with our Fourier
transform approximation is we're trying
to approximate this mountain land
scape of the pixel intensity as a sum of
sine and cosine waves in X and in Y and
at different frequencies so we're gonna
add up all of those kind of wavy sheets
in just the right proportion in this
proportion and we're gonna reconstruct
this topography of pixel intensities to
reconstruct her face okay so I'm just
gonna go back and see if I can get this
from another perspective okay so this is
looking a top-down right at the image
let's see if I can grab this and move it
down and again I'm just going to move
this around a little bit so you can see
and we're going to move this out of the
plane now you can start to see that
there's actually this mountainous
landscape to represent all of those
pixels and their intensity okay so I
think that's a really cool visualization
to help you understand that these images
kind of the the intensity of these
images do in fact form some kind of a
three-dimensional intensity landscape if
you will and this is kind of what we're
trying to approximate with our Fourier
transform using these wavy these wavy
sheets in X Y okay and I always think of
you know two people four people on on
all four sides of a bedsheet so they
hold it tight and they start pumping the
bedsheet in the x-direction at some
frequency they pump the bedsheet in the
y-direction at some frequency and they
get this standing wave that's one
Fourier coefficient and if you add all
of those standing waves up in just the
right proportion
you'll reconstruct this landscape with
those two mountain peaks at the eyes and
and every other feature and you'll
actually reconstruct that that face okay
so that's image compression using the
FFT next we're going to look at wavelet
image compression okay thank you